malgré la répression la contestation ne
faiblit pas plus d'un mois après le coup
de force militaire et des milliers de
personnes sont une nouvelle fois
descendus dans les rues des principales
villes du pays ce jeudi un mouvement de
contestation que la junte semble de plus
en plus déterminé à écraser
d'après l'onu au moins 38 personnes ont
été tuées mercredi par les forces de
sécurité qui ont tiré à balles réelles
sur les manifestants
une journée sanglante que les civils ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
on ne leur pardonnera pas ce qu'ils ont
fait pas seulement pour cette fille mais
aussi pour les autres qui ont sacrifié
leur vie
elle n'oubliera pas ce qu'ils ont fait
le moment venu la multiplication des
violences a provoqué de nouvelles
réactions de la part des dirigeants
occidentaux
emmanuel macron a réclamé l'arrêt
immédiat de la répression
boris johnson en a fait de même et s'est
dit horrifié par la situation
discours similaire aux états unis qui
ont annoncé ce jeudi des nouvelles
sanctions commerciales
les états unis prennent des mesures
contre les responsables du coup d'état
en birmanie
aujourd'hui le ministère du commerce a
annoncé de nouvelles restrictions pour
imposer des coûts au régime militaire
birman nous continuerons d'agir contre
la junte
et d'appeler à la démocratie en birmanie
de son côté pékin se concentre sur la
stabilité politique et sociale du pays
la chine a eu des contacts avec toutes
les parties en birmanie et a activement
encouragé la désescalade de la situation
nous encourageons les pays de la séan à
respecter les principes du consensus et
de la non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures à rester attachés à l'unité
et la coopération au sein de la famille
de aseal et à promouvoir activement la
désescalade de la situation en birmanie
de la façon dont la cnc le faire nous
pensons que toute action de la
communauté internationale devrait
contribuer à la
habilité politique et sociale de la
birmanie à sa réconciliation pacifique
et éviter d'aggraver les conflits et de
compliquer davantage la situation
en plus des violences dans la rue la
répression se déroule aussi dans les
tribunaux toujours incarcérés hansson
sushi est visé par quatre chefs
d'inculpation dont incitation aux
troubles publics
six journalistes sont également
poursuivis par la justice et encourt
jusqu'à trois ans de prison